time now for morning rounds are look at
the medical news of the week beginning
with the use of statins after a heart
attack patients who suffer heart attacks
are often given prescriptions for the
powerful drugs which have been shown to
help prevent future heart problems but
our patients following through on the
treatment a recent study in the american
medical associations cardiology journal
looked at nearly 58,000 Medicare
patients 66 and older who were
discharged from a hospital following a
heart attack they were given high dosage
statin prescriptions within 30 days of
leaving the hospital the primary goal of
the study was to see if patients stayed
on them statin medications CBS News
contributor dr. Tara narula is here with
more hi Tara hi Anthony did the people
keep up they did not they did not very
disheartening as a cardiologist but the
adherence rates were not great and
statins are really life-saving
medications not just for patients with
coronary artery disease in general but
particularly for patients post heart
attack and in this study when they
looked at the six-month rate of
adherence it was about fifty nine
percent to reported being high adheres
at six months that dropped down to about
forty two percent at two years when they
looked at those over the age of 75 the
numbers were similar at two years the
high adheres high adherence rate was
around thirty-nine percent not great so
what can you do me the stakes seem
fairly high enough here what do you need
to do to convince people to take their
medications yeah the stakes are really
high and you know there was a study in
2012 that showed about twenty to thirty
percent of scripts are not filled fifty
percent of medications for chronic
diseases are not taken as prescribed and
this cost our country hundreds of
billions of dollars yeah so what can we
do a lot of my patients talk about using
their pharmacist as a really great
resource having open lines of
communication with your doctor to
express your fears and concerns as
opposed to just stopping taking your
medication in general getting some
education working with care coordinators
having telephone calls arrive to your
home that remind you to take your
medication simplifying regiments so
pillboxes combining medication times
with neil times and then lower co-pays
all of that yes take your medication
please alright our next topic sleep
before school I remember this one
parents and teachers often give the same
advice to
get enough sleep but according to a cdc
analysis of surveys during an average
school night sixty-eight percent of high
schoolers reported getting seven hours
or less of slumber and thirty-two
percent got eight hours or more the
American Academy of Sleep Medicine
recommends teens 13 to 18 years old get
eight to ten hours on a regular basis
this month the same group released a
position statement regarding school
start times for middle and high schools
okay I wish I had got 10 hours of sleep
during high school Tara but what did the
Academy suggest regarding school start
times yes so sleep time so important for
our children and while we may want them
to go to bed at nine o'clock in the
evening or earlier three months dream on
as you know with teenagers actually
their circadian rhythm is delayed they
have delayed secretion of melatonin so
for many of them it's hard to get to bed
before eleven o'clock at night so by
pushing the school start time back to
830 you are hope the hope is that you
can get in that eight to ten hours that
really is recommended and right now
about sixty eight percent of teenagers
are getting less than seven hours so the
idea is that with more sleep you improve
alertness at school you improve driving
safety and avoidable accidents you also
increase mental health and well-being so
there are a lot of potential good side
effects of pushing that start time back
it's also an issue of how much homework
the teachers give you by the way when
you get your kid to bed but that's the
other matter but and pushing back the
time doesn't necessarily mean better
sleep though does it no and that's where
we come in as parents I mean so many
adults are really bad about practicing
good sleep hygiene so we need to start
to teach our kids at a younger age that
this is a priority yeah and so they need
to go to sleep in a cool dark room turn
off devices early so you don't get that
blue light that can interfere with the
secretion of melatonin you need to
practice going to bed and waking up at
the same time every day in addition to
weekends and also having a bedtime
routine just like we teach our our
little little ones to have a bedtime
routine we need to do that for our teens
sleep is delicious and they need to
learn it at a young age exactly a
never-ending
finally texting it's how many of us
communicate but should we be keeping our
backs and necks in mind while doing it
according to a recent article in the
spine journal I have a subscription
surgeons noted they are seeing more
cases of various back and neck issues
and prolonged use of smart phones and
texting is considered a possible culprit
since when texting you're often using a
forward flexed neck position that would
look like what I'm doing with all day
long it's even led to the term text neck
the authors advise caution especially
with children's and cell phone use is
starting at young ages while the spine
is still developing they did have some
tips for textures such as holding phones
up at or near eye level like so i don't
natural right so natural and the use of
two hands and two thumbs for a more
comfortable position but then everybody
can read what i'm texting they pointed
to another article that said at neutral
position ur head weighs about 10 to 12
pounds but when you tilt it about 60
degrees relatively increases about 60
pounds Wow a lot of force on the
cervical spine so no yeah x neck i was
napping a little hat with something to
hold it up we going to actually if they
raise your arms that I dr. Tara narula
thank you for your wisdom on this into
my own topics